well it's the homecoming we've been
waiting to share with you a las vegas
man who came to the u.s after working as
an interpreter for the u.s military in
afghanistan finally reunites with his
wife he says people reached out to help
him after we first interviewed him it's
an exclusive you'll only see on eight
news now
[Music]
this is what an embrace after a long
journey looks like for heck matt gauzy
and his wife laylee they still don't
believe that she's here it's the first
time they've seen each other in six
months they married a year ago in
afghanistan and honeymoon six months ago
in dubai but hekmat had to return to las
vegas without her until she get the
proper documentation to enter the united
states
the taliban takeover in august brought
with it great urgency and fear as laylee
had to remain in hiding i'm making
attempts to get in the airport and going
through thousands of people and shots
being fired people being beaten this
photo showing the relief as laylee and
her brother learned they are on a
special flight out of kabul from there
to qatar and then fort mccoy in
wisconsin she spends several weeks at an
integration training program for afghan
refugees the evening she flies into las
vegas hekmat learned that laylee's
father has passed away like it was a
mixed feeling you know it's like i lost
a father figure
and now i'm responsible for the family
that's left back there he and laylee
continue efforts to help other afghan
refugees and interpreters with the
non-profit freedom support alliance
which he runs with his friend bahir
shirzad we're actually working for the
afghan community here to help them you
know for the better future
lely is here on an immigrant visa as a
spouse of a u.s citizen freedom support
alliance has partnered with concerned
veterans of america to host a community
event for all afghans october 8 helping
them connect with resources in our area
and assist if they're looking for a job